Kayak gets my flight, hotel, and rental car right, so I can tune out travel advice that's just plain wrong. Bro, Skycoin, way better than points. Never fly during a Scorpio full moon. Just tell the manager you'll sue. Instant room upgrade. Stop taking bad travel advice. Start comparing hundreds of sites with kayak and get your trip right. Bad advice?
Kayak 帮我搞定了机票、酒店和租车，所以我可以屏蔽掉那些完全错误的旅行建议。兄弟，Skycoin 比积分好用多了。千万别在天蝎座满月时坐飞机。只要告诉经理你要起诉他们，就能立刻升级房间。别再听信糟糕的旅行建议了。开始用 Kayak 对比数百个网站，让你的旅行不出错。糟糕的建议？
You talking to me? Kayak, got that right. More than 50 years ago, in 1972, researchers in Dunedin, New Zealand began an ambitious study. They enrolled every baby born in the city that year, more than 1,000 babies in all, in a study designed to learn more about childhood health and development. Remarkably, that study is still going on. As the participants have moved from babyhood to childhood to adulthood, data from the Dunedin study has led to more than 1,400 research papers
你在跟我说话吗？Kayak，说得对。50 多年前，也就是 1972 年，新西兰达尼丁的研究人员开始了一项雄心勃勃的研究。他们将当年在该市出生的每一个婴儿——总共 1000 多名——都纳入了一项旨在深入了解儿童健康与发展的研究中。值得注意的是，这项研究至今仍在进行。随着参与者从婴儿期步入童年再到成年，达尼丁研究的数据已经产出了 1400 多篇研究论文，
that have examined how people's genetics and life experiences shape their lives. Now, as the participants enter middle age, the researchers have turned their attention to the next life stage, aging. Today we're going to talk to a psychologist who's helped lead the Dunedin's study for nearly four decades about what researchers are learning about how we age, why some people age faster or slower than others, and how early intervention might help forestall some of the challenges that come with growing older. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
这些论文探讨了人类的基因和生活经历如何塑造他们的人生。现在，随着参与者步入中年，研究人员将注意力转向了下一个人生阶段——衰老。今天，我们将与一位参与领导达尼丁研究近四十年的心理学家交谈，探讨研究人员在衰老方面的发现，为什么有些人衰老得更快或更慢，以及早期干预如何帮助预防衰老过程中带来的一些挑战。欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，
that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Terry Moffitt, the Associate Director of the Dunedin Longitudinal Study, which she joined in 1986. She's also the Nancohean University Professor of Psychology at Duke University and Professor of Social Development at King's College London. Dr. Moffett has wide-ranging expertise in longitudinal methods, developmental theory, clinical mental health research, neuropsychology, and genomics in behavioral science.
该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是 Kim Mills。我今天的嘉宾是达尼丁纵向研究的副主任 Terry Moffitt 博士，她于 1986 年加入该研究。她同时也是杜克大学的 Nancohean 心理学教授和伦敦国王学院的社会发展学教授。Moffitt 博士在纵向研究方法、发展理论、临床心理健康研究、神经心理学以及行为科学的基因组学方面拥有广泛的专业知识。
Now her work is uncovering the consequences of a lifetime of mental and behavioral disorder on processes of aging. Dr. Moffat is the author of hundreds of scientific papers and has received many awards for her work, including APA's Early Career Contribution Award and Distinguished Career Award. She's a fellow of the British Academy, the Academy of Medical Sciences in the UK, and the National Academy of Medicine. Dr. Moffat, thank you for joining me today. Good to see you, Kim. So we're going to talk mainly about aging today, but I wanted to start by asking you to tell us a little more about your work over the years with the Dunedin study,
现在，她的工作正在揭示终身心理和行为障碍对衰老过程的影响。Moffitt 博士撰写了数百篇科学论文，并因其工作获得了许多奖项，包括美国心理学会的早期职业贡献奖和杰出职业生涯奖。她是英国科学院、英国医学科学院和美国国家医学院的院士。Moffitt 博士，感谢您今天参加我们的节目。很高兴见到你，Kim。我们今天主要谈论衰老，但我还是想先请您多介绍一下您多年来在达尼丁研究中的工作，
which you originally joined when the participants were teenagers. How did you get involved with this study and what were you interested in then? Oh, that's a great question. a historical one. I got involved with the Dunedin study fresh out of graduate school. All my friends said, don't go to New Zealand, you'll disappear. But the data were there. It was a wonderful longitudinal study.
您最初是在参与者还是青少年时加入这项研究的。您是如何参与这项研究的，当时您对什么感兴趣？哦，这是一个很好的问题，一个历史性的问题。我刚从研究生院毕业就参与了达尼丁研究。我所有的朋友都说，别去新西兰，你会消失的。但数据就在那里。这是一项非常棒的纵向研究。
And the team at the University of Otago invited me to collect data to my heart's content. They've been a wonderful group to collaborate with over the years. I can't say anything better about my colleagues. collaborators at Otago. So the study has gathered an amazing amount and variety of information about the participants over the years. Can you tell us something about the data that's been collected and what are some of the most interesting findings that have come out of it? Let's see. With the Denise study, you know, when I first joined, I was interested in, the reason for going there was to really study how teenagers got involved in delinquency and drug use
奥塔哥大学的团队邀请我随心所欲地收集数据。多年来，他们一直是一个非常棒的合作团队。对于我在奥塔哥的同事和合作者，我怎么夸奖都不为过。所以，多年来，这项研究收集了关于参与者的大量且多样化的信息。您能告诉我们一些关于所收集的数据，以及从中得出的一些最有趣的发现吗？让我想想。关于达尼丁研究，你知道，我最初加入时，去那里的原因确实是为了研究青少年如何参与犯罪和吸毒，
and risky sex and other tricky things that young people do when they're teenagers. and most importantly, to keep following the cohort as they grew out of that. So to see what happened that helped people leave crime behind and become good upstanding stivis. But what happened is that they did leave crime behind and they outgrew it. And I'm still working with the Dunedin cohort 35 years later, but we needed to really keep up with what was happening to the study members. And what started to be really the most important thing in their life was aging. So they're reaching midlife. They're concerned about the rest of their lives and so that we had to keep up with them. Is that common to leave crime behind? Do you really outgrow it in some cases? Most people who participate in crime when they
以及危险性行为和年轻人青少年时期会做的其他棘手事情。最重要的是，在他们成长过程中持续跟踪这个群体。看看是什么因素帮助人们摆脱犯罪，成为优秀的公民。但事实是，他们确实摆脱了犯罪，并随着年龄增长而不再那样做了。35 年后，我仍在与达尼丁队列合作，但我们需要真正跟上研究成员身上发生的事情。而开始成为他们生活中最重要的事情是衰老。他们正在步入中年。他们关心余生，所以我们必须跟上他们的步伐。摆脱犯罪是普遍现象吗？在某些情况下，人们真的会随着年龄增长而不再犯罪吗？大多数在青少年时期参与犯罪的人，
are teenagers do leave it behind in their 20s. They get the things that criminologists tell us and psychologists tell us are great for leaving crime behind. That is a good partner and a good job. So that's a normal developmental stage. There are, of course, a few adolescent delinquent offenders who aren't able to leave crime behind and who end up sinking further and further into an antisocial lifestyle. And in their case, we found that they, as they grow older, they can also get partners. They can also get jobs, but they tend to bring their antisocial behavior with them to those new situations. And so they will be getting involved in intimate partner violence. They'll be getting involved in work time. So it's been very interesting
在 20 多岁时确实会摆脱它。他们获得了犯罪学家和心理学家告诉我们的那些对摆脱犯罪非常有益的东西。那就是好的伴侣和好的工作。所以这是一个正常的发育阶段。当然，也有少数青少年犯罪者无法摆脱犯罪，最终越陷越深，陷入反社会的生活方式。对于他们，我们发现，随着年龄增长，他们也可以找到伴侣，也可以找到工作，但他们往往会将反社会行为带入这些新环境中。因此，他们会卷入亲密伴侣暴力，卷入工作场所冲突。所以，跟踪这些年轻人长大成人是非常有趣的，
to follow those young people as they've grown up, but they are a small, small number. How unusual is this study? Are there others like it that have studied so many participants for such a long period of time? There are a lot of cohort studies that are going on around the world, primarily in Britain, Canada, Scandinavia, now more new ones. starting up in the United States. Some are much, much bigger. Some have been going on much longer, some of the ones in Britain. But the thing about the Dunedin study, what makes it really special is the depth and breadth of the data collection. So in our study, all of the participants come into the clinic and get a day-long, in-depth clinical assessment by professional clinicians. So that's
但他们只是极少数。这项研究有多不寻常？还有其他类似的研究，在如此长的时间内研究了这么多参与者吗？世界各地正在进行许多队列研究，主要是在英国、加拿大、斯堪的纳维亚，现在美国也开始出现更多新的研究。有些规模大得多。有些进行的时间更长，比如英国的一些研究。但达尼丁研究的特别之处在于数据收集的深度和广度。在我们的研究中，所有的参与者都会来到诊所，接受专业临床医生为期一天的深入临床评估。所以这
quite different than taking part in a longitudinal, say, telephone survey or online survey. This is kind of a nuts and bolts question, but how is something like that funded over such a long period of time? Who is paying all of the money that's gone into the Dunedin study? The funding has to be renewed every five years, and there's always a mad scramble. Luckily, writing proposals is something I really love to do. It was a bit strange, but I do love it. And my collaborators in New Zealand write proposals to the New Zealand Health Research Council and the Ministry of Business and Industry. And I write proposals to the National Institute on Aging in the United States and the Medical Research Council in Britain. So those are our main funders,
与参加纵向的电话调查或在线调查完全不同。这是一个比较基础的问题，但像这样的项目在如此长的时间内是如何获得资助的？是谁在支付达尼丁研究的所有费用？资金必须每五年更新一次，而且总是会有一场疯狂的争夺。幸运的是，撰写提案是我真正喜欢做的事情。这有点奇怪，但我确实喜欢它。我在新西兰的合作者向新西兰健康研究委员会以及商业和工业部提交提案。而我则向美国的国家老龄化研究所和英国的医学研究委员会提交提案。所以这些是我们主要的资助者，
and they all sort of collaborate with each other to make sure that their money goes for the topics that they're most interested in. Let's talk about the most recent focus of the study, which is aging. have developed a test called Dunedin Pace, which measures the rate of people's biological aging. Tell us more about what that means. What's biological aging? How does the test work? So one of the important things to think about biological aging is quite obvious. It's different from chronological aging. So you can have a group of people, as we have all of the Dunedin study members born in 1972, 73, they're all exactly the same age, but their biological age can range, you know, 10 or 15 years around their chronological age.
他们都会相互协作，确保他们的资金用于他们最感兴趣的主题。让我们谈谈该研究最近的重点，即衰老。你们开发了一种名为“达尼丁步伐”（Dunedin Pace）的测试，用于测量人们的生物学衰老速度。请告诉我们这意味着什么。什么是生物学衰老？这个测试是如何工作的？关于生物学衰老，有一点很重要，那就是它很明显。它不同于生理年龄（按出生日期计算的年龄）。所以你可以有一群人，就像我们达尼丁研究中所有 1972 年、73 年出生的人一样，他们年龄完全相同，但他们的生物学年龄可以在生理年龄的基础上上下浮动 10 或 15 年。
Some people are growing old very fast as compared to their peers in the cohort. Some people are growing old much more slowly and retaining their youthful vigor. So we were interested in being able to measure that. We set about doing it by using our longitudinal data, longitudinal approach, and I'll go into a bit of depth because that's really what sets our approach apart from all the other ways of measuring aging that you might be hearing of out there. So we measured the study members, 19 biomarkers tracking their organ systems, say their heart, their lungs, their teeth even, all over the body, the function of the kidneys, inflammation, their immune system. We tracked those biomarkers by drawing them at age 26, age 32, age 38, and age 45. So over 20 years, and now we're topping it up at age 52 this year, over 20 years we have a record of how each study member's biology and biological organ function has declined over the entire body.
有些人与同龄人相比衰老得非常快。有些人衰老得慢得多，保持着青春活力。所以我们有兴趣能够测量这一点。我们通过使用纵向数据、纵向方法着手进行这项工作，我会深入讲解一下，因为这正是我们的方法区别于你可能听到的所有其他衰老测量方式的地方。我们测量了研究成员的 19 种生物标志物，追踪他们的器官系统，比如心脏、肺、甚至牙齿，全身各处，肾脏功能、炎症、免疫系统。我们通过在 26 岁、32 岁、38 岁和 45 岁时抽取样本来追踪这些生物标志物。所以超过 20 年，今年我们将在 52 岁时进行补充，超过 20 年，我们记录了每个研究成员的生物学和生物器官功能在全身范围内的衰退情况。
That gives us then the capacity to track for each individual person whether they are aging faster biologically or slower biologically than the average typical person. So we have inherent norms. Psychologists understand that, and that's very important. That's what makes the measure really special. You will hear of many, many, many different aging clocks out there. It's been the holy grail to try to find how to measure age. The last five years, the research has really gotten very exciting and blown up,
这使我们有能力为每个人追踪他们是在生物学上衰老得更快，还是比普通人衰老得更慢。所以我们有内在的常模。心理学家理解这一点，这非常重要。这就是使该测量方法真正特别的原因。你会听到很多很多不同的“衰老时钟”。试图找到如何测量年龄一直是圣杯。过去五年，这项研究确实变得非常令人兴奋并爆发式增长，
and there have been lots of different clocks that are published. What says to the end pace apart from all the others is it is longitudinal. It really tracks actual change over time. All of the others, so far, are based on cross-sectional data. So they may predict mortality. They may have, they use information about smoking. They may use information about art function. They may use proteomics and other kinds of exciting omics.
已经发表了许多不同的时钟。Dunedin Pace 与其他所有时钟的区别在于它是纵向的。它确实追踪了随时间发生的实际变化。到目前为止，所有其他的时钟都是基于横断面数据。所以它们可能预测死亡率。它们可能使用吸烟信息。它们可能使用心脏功能信息。它们可能使用蛋白质组学和其他令人兴奋的组学。
But if they are based on one cross-sectional piece of data taken at one point in time, they don't actually document that a person is aging. I'm curious about how you determine all of this. So like do I, like a 23 and Me type of test where you spit in a test tube, I mean, how do you determine the age of somebody's biological systems? Right. Well, we had our model that we had built with the data from the 1,000 Daneden study members by tracking them through time by testing their biomarkers. That was great, but nobody else could do that. So like your doctor won't be able to do it when you go into a clinic. Other researchers couldn't even do it if they didn't have 20 years of longitudinal data. They wouldn't be able to actually just replicate our findings.
但如果它们是基于在某一个时间点采集的一个横断面数据，它们实际上并不能证明一个人正在衰老。我很好奇你们是如何确定所有这些的。就像 23andMe 那种吐口水的测试一样，我的意思是，你们如何确定某人生物系统的年龄？对。好吧，我们有我们用 1000 名达尼丁研究成员的数据建立的模型，通过随时间追踪他们，测试他们的生物标志物。这很棒，但其他人做不到。所以你的医生在你去诊所时无法做到这一点。其他研究人员如果他们没有 20 年的纵向数据，甚至无法做到这一点。他们无法真正复制我们的发现。
and we know replication is so important in psychology research. So what we had to do was we had to turn this model of individual differences among people in how fast or slow they're aging into something that can be done in a single blood test. So that's where the Dunedin-Pace idea comes in. What you do is we obtain DNA from every Denetan study member, all 1,000 study members. we subjected it to DNA methylation array. So those are the epigenetic marks that are on top of your genes. And those epigenetic marks change with age.
我们知道复制在心理学研究中非常重要。所以我们必须做的是，将这个关于人们衰老速度快慢的个体差异模型转化为一种可以通过单次血液测试完成的东西。这就是 Dunedin Pace 概念的由来。你所做的是，我们从每一位达尼丁研究成员那里获取 DNA，所有 1000 名成员。我们对其进行了 DNA 甲基化阵列分析。这些就是你基因之上的表观遗传标记。而这些表观遗传标记会随年龄变化。
So we were able to then link those marks, identify the ones that best characterize people in the Dunedin cohort who were either aging fast or slow, and then use those to create a measure that if you have someone's DNA and you have a, you can just look at it and you can see very swiftly whether they're aging fast or slow. So that allowed us to export it so that other research teams, all they needed was a bit of blood to get the DNA. And it's been offered direct to consumer. So even individuals can obtain this test. And you just prick your finger, you get a drop of blood that goes onto a little
因此，我们能够将这些标记联系起来，识别出最能表征达尼丁队列中衰老快或慢的人的标记，然后利用这些标记创建一个测量方法，如果你有某人的 DNA，你只需看一眼，就能非常迅速地看出他们是衰老得快还是慢。这使我们能够将其导出，以便其他研究团队只需要一点血液来获取 DNA。它已经直接面向消费者提供。所以即使是个人也可以获得这项测试。你只需刺破手指，取一滴血滴在小小的
piece of filter paper and then you dry the filter paper and you send it in to the lab for the assay. Do people's biological systems tend to age in the same way at the same time or can your body be kind of all over the place where one organ is this age and another organ is older and so forth? This one is tricky because the field of geroscience says its theory is that what makes aging different from just having a disease. How do you know, like if your biomarker, if you're, say, HBA1C is elevated or your cholesterol is elevated, some kind of biomarker is elevated, your inflammation is elevated, how do you know whether that's because you just right now have a disease or are we tapping into your aging? Well, one way we know is we track it longitudinally,
滤纸片上，然后晾干滤纸，寄回实验室进行化验。人们的生物系统往往会以同样的方式在同一时间衰老吗？还是说你的身体可能到处都是问题，一个器官是这个年龄，另一个器官更老，以此类推？这一点很棘手，因为老年科学领域认为，其理论是衰老与仅仅患有疾病的区别。你怎么知道，如果你的生物标志物，比如你的糖化血红蛋白（HBA1C）升高了，或者胆固醇升高了，某种生物标志物升高了，炎症升高了，你怎么知道这是因为你现在刚好患有疾病，还是我们正在触及你的衰老？好吧，我们知道的一种方法是我们进行纵向追踪，
and that helps us to determine whether someone is just sick at the moment or whether they're on a fast aging trajectory. If you have elevated biomarkers at one point in time, but you didn't have higher scores before and lower scores after, then you're not following a trajectory of aging. And it needs to be with all of your organ systems following the same trajectory, which is what makes it the whole body is aging. As opposed, let's say that all of your other biomarkers were normal
这有助于我们确定某人是此刻生病了，还是处于快速衰老的轨迹上。如果你在某一个时间点有升高的生物标志物，但之前没有更高的分数，之后也没有更低的分数，那么你并没有遵循衰老的轨迹。而且必须是你的所有器官系统都遵循相同的轨迹，这才是全身都在衰老。相反，假设你的所有其他生物标志物都是正常的，
and just the only the inflammation one was raised, or only the respiratory one would raise. But that would tell us nothing about aging. It would tell us you probably have COVID. So what are some of the other factors that influence one's biological age? There are lots of different things turning up in the literature. And in fact, since we published the Demitin piece and put it on the algorithm on GitHub so that other researchers could use it, There've been over 160 publications from other teams, and they've shown all kinds of interesting things. So one of the things that influences how fast you're aging is obvious. All of your listeners can easily guess that's smoking.
只有炎症指标升高了，或者只有呼吸系统指标升高了。那对衰老说明不了什么。那只会告诉我们你可能得了新冠。那么还有哪些因素会影响一个人的生物学年龄？文献中出现了许多不同的东西。事实上，自从我们发布了 Dunedin Pace 并将其算法放在 GitHub 上以便其他研究人员使用以来，已经有超过 160 篇来自其他团队的出版物，他们展示了各种有趣的事情。所以影响你衰老速度的因素之一很明显。你们所有的听众都能轻易猜到，那就是吸烟。
So nothing exciting and new there. But we've also seen papers that are reporting that, let's say from the Health and Retirement study reporting that people who were in infant development during the Great Depression, those whose families were the poorest, now that they are in their 60s and 70s, they're aging the fastest. So there can be quite long-term effects, and a lot of the effects that we're seeing are from childhood adversity. There are also some papers that are reporting influences on the pace of aging from racial being a recipient of racial discrimination, so that kind of current intense stressor can also accelerate the pace of aging. No one goes to Hank's for his spreadsheets. They go for a darn good pizza. Lately, though, the shop's been quiet.
所以没什么令人兴奋的新发现。但我们也看到了一些论文，比如来自《健康与退休研究》的报告称，那些在大萧条时期处于婴儿发育阶段的人，那些家庭最贫困的人，现在他们 60 多岁和 70 多岁了，他们衰老得最快。所以可能会有相当长期的影响，而且我们看到的许多影响都来自童年逆境。还有一些论文报告了种族歧视对衰老速度的影响，所以那种持续的强烈压力源也会加速衰老。没人会因为 Hank 的电子表格而去他的店里。他们去是为了那美味的披萨。不过最近，店里一直很冷清。
So Hank decides to bring back the $1 slice. He asks co-pilot in Microsoft Excel to look at his sales and costs. Help him see if he can afford it. Co-pilot shows Hank where the money's going and which little extras make the dollar. slice work. Now, Hank has a line out the door. Hank makes the pizza. Co-Pilot handles the spreadsheets. Learn more at M365 copilot.com slash work. Do you give all of that information to the study participants? Do they know what their biological ages are? Or would that influence the outcome? Yeah, Daneden's study participants are quite awesome and amazing 1,000 people. When they first began this study years and years ago, of course, their parents signed, them up. But the agreement at the time was that this would be a study of natural development
所以 Hank 决定带回 1 美元的披萨切片。他让 Microsoft Excel 中的 Copilot 查看他的销售额和成本。帮他看看他是否负担得起。Copilot 向 Hank 展示了钱花在了哪里，以及哪些小细节让 1 美元的切片变得可行。现在，Hank 的店门口排起了长队。Hank 做披萨。Copilot 处理电子表格。在 M365 copilot.com/work 了解更多信息。你们会把所有这些信息提供给研究参与者吗？他们知道自己的生物学年龄吗？还是说这会影响结果？是的，达尼丁研究的参与者是非常棒和了不起的 1000 人。当他们多年前刚开始这项研究时，当然，他们的父母为他们报了名。但当时的协议是，这将是一项自然发展的研究，
with no intervention and the research team would not be given feedback. Now, we do give feedback, of course, if someone is in danger, if their life is in danger. But if so long as it's not an unusual danger to life and limb, we don't typically give feedback. And the study members get that. They really understand the value of having a study of natural development. So they're hugely patient with us and very generous. So if I take a home test and I discover that my biological and chronological ages are out of sync, what can I do to put them in sync? Well, this is another thing that's coming out in the literature.
没有干预，研究团队也不会提供反馈。现在，如果有人处于危险之中，如果他们的生命处于危险之中，我们当然会提供反馈。但只要不是对生命和肢体造成异常危险，我们通常不会提供反馈。研究成员也理解这一点。他们真正理解进行一项自然发展研究的价值。所以他们对我们非常有耐心，也非常慷慨。那么，如果我进行了一项家庭测试，发现我的生物学年龄和生理年龄不同步，我该怎么做才能让它们同步呢？好吧，这是文献中出现的另一件事。
A lot of different papers starting to come out showing, you know, of course there are people in the longevity industry who are really keen on find, drugs and medications that people could take to slow their aging. But there are also health behaviors that you can do. So one of the things you can do is, you know, join a gym, lose weight, control your sleep. So there's a lot of different experimental studies that are using the Dunditin Pace-of-Aging measure as their outcome, giving it before the experimental intervention, and then taking it again after and to test whether people are able to slow their aging. One of the most famous of these studies is the calorie study in which participants in the trial arm,
很多不同的论文开始出现，显示，当然，长寿行业里有一些人非常热衷于寻找人们可以服用的药物和药物来减缓衰老。但也有你可以做的健康行为。所以你可以做的一件事是，你知道，去健身房，减肥，控制睡眠。所以有很多不同的实验研究正在使用“达尼丁衰老步伐”测量作为他们的结果，在实验干预前进行测量，然后在干预后再次测量，以测试人们是否能够减缓衰老。这些研究中最著名的是卡路里研究，其中试验组的参与者，
the intervention arm, agreed to eat less than 1,800 calories a day for two years. And awesomely, they were able to do that. I'm not sure if I could, but they did and they were able to slow their pace of aging as compared to the people who were, were allowed to just eat whatever they wanted. What are some of the ways that this information is being used now? I mean, how are you applying the aging research to the public at large? What my team is doing is we are making sure that the measure, you know, it was developed in white New Zealanders.
干预组，同意每天摄入少于 1800 卡路里的热量，持续两年。令人惊叹的是，他们能够做到这一点。我不确定我是否能做到，但他们做到了，而且与那些被允许随意吃东西的人相比，他们能够减缓衰老速度。这些信息现在有哪些应用方式？我的意思是，你们如何将衰老研究应用于大众？我的团队正在做的是，我们确保该测量方法，你知道，它是在白人新西兰人身上开发的。
Let's just say that. So one really big question that was out there for us and for everyone else in the field, too is would it work for Asian Americans, African Americans, Hispanic Americans, people of all different kinds of groups in the population? So systematically, we've been going through and finding datasets that have participants from different ethnic groups. And other teams have been doing that too. So for example, the Danin Pace has been applied in the Taiwanese bio bank of Chinese. So some very huge samples of people in different ethnic groups. So far, it's still predicting everything it should predict. It's predicting future disease risk. It's predicting dementia. It's predicting early mortality.
我们就这么说吧。所以对于我们和领域内的其他人来说，一个非常大的问题是，它是否适用于亚裔美国人、非裔美国人、西班牙裔美国人，以及人口中各种不同群体的人？所以我们一直在系统地寻找拥有不同族裔参与者的数据集。其他团队也在这样做。例如，Dunedin Pace 已应用于台湾的华人生物银行。所以一些在不同族裔群体中非常庞大的样本。到目前为止，它仍然在预测它应该预测的一切。它正在预测未来的疾病风险。它正在预测痴呆症。它正在预测早期死亡率。
And it's related to factors such as childhood adversity and health behaviors in the different ethnic groups. You mentioned early on that you got involved in this study because you were looking at criminal behavior over time. And I'm wondering, what else has the Dunedin study looked at besides that and now aging? The Dunedin study has, its full name is the Dunedin Multidisciplinary Health and Development Study. That's a mouthful. But the multidisciplinary part helps to explain why the study members have to stay at the clinic for an eight-hour day. Then they sleep overnight and they return the following morning and they have a brain scan. So there's a whole neuroimaging, behavioral neuroimaging part to the study that's directed by Amad Hariri and myself. But there's a team that studies injury.
并且它与不同族裔群体中的童年逆境和健康行为等因素有关。您早些时候提到您参与这项研究是因为您在观察长期的犯罪行为。我想知道，除了那个和现在的衰老，达尼丁研究还研究了什么？达尼丁研究的全称是“达尼丁多学科健康与发展研究”。这名字很长。但多学科部分有助于解释为什么研究成员必须在诊所待上一整天。然后他们过夜，第二天早上回来，他们会进行脑部扫描。所以研究中有一个完整的神经影像、行为神经影像部分，由 Amad Hariri 和我指导。但有一个团队研究损伤。
There's a team that studies respiratory medicine, asthma, allergies, lung capacity. There's a team that studies vision. There's a team that studies hearing. There's a team that studies cardiovascular health. So it really is a whole group of teams that get together. And some of them are based in New Zealand. Some are based in the United States. Historically, one of the respiratory teams was in Canada, but now they're in New Zealand.
有一个团队研究呼吸医学、哮喘、过敏、肺活量。有一个团队研究视力。有一个团队研究听力。有一个团队研究心血管健康。所以它确实是一个由多个团队组成的整体。其中一些位于新西兰。一些位于美国。历史上，其中一个呼吸团队在加拿大，但现在他们在新西兰。
So it's an international study, but also covering all the different aspects of life, really. And I should say also there's neuropsychological testing that takes place for a very large neuropsychological test battery, a mental health, standard diagnostic interview, and interviews about family life, work life, relationships with family members. So it's a very exhausting day. When the study members check in at 8 and they don't leave until 530, the last thing they do is give blood, they're really, really tired. And how have you managed to keep in touch with so many of them for so many years. Yeah, this is something that the team at the University of Otago in New Zealand is just awesome at. They have built up trust, faith, respect, mutual respect with the study members
所以这是一项国际研究，但也涵盖了生活的各个方面，真的。我还应该说，还有进行的神经心理学测试，一个非常大的神经心理学测试电池，心理健康，标准的诊断访谈，以及关于家庭生活、工作生活、与家庭成员关系的访谈。所以这是非常令人疲惫的一天。当研究成员在 8 点签到，直到 5 点 30 分才离开，他们做的最后一件事是抽血，他们真的非常非常累。你们是如何设法在这么多年里与他们中的这么多人保持联系的。是的，这是新西兰奥塔哥大学的团队非常擅长的事情。他们建立了信任、信念、尊重，与研究成员之间的相互尊重，
over the many years of the study. We have extensive records because every time a study member comes into to take part, they give us contact information for family and friends who could help us find them next time. So they're they're keen to be found if they've moved overseas or something like that. And they help us out with that. The study is really, you know, a jewel in the crown of New Zealand science. People there are super proud of it, super proud to be part of it. And they refer to themselves as anonymously famous because we have kept their confidentiality all these years. never reveal even who's in the study. So that's kind of interesting. It's a small country, but we've been able to keep their confidentiality. Now, I mean, epigenetics is a relatively new
在研究的多年里。我们有详尽的记录，因为每次研究成员来参加时，他们都会给我们提供家庭成员和朋友的联系信息，他们可以帮助我们在下次找到他们。所以如果他们搬到海外或其他地方，他们很乐意被找到。他们在这方面帮助我们。这项研究确实是新西兰科学皇冠上的明珠。那里的人们对此感到非常自豪，非常自豪能成为其中的一部分。他们称自己为“匿名名人”，因为我们多年来一直为他们保密。甚至从未透露谁在研究中。所以这很有趣。这是一个小国家，但我们已经能够为他们保密。现在，我的意思是，表观遗传学是一个相对较新的
field. I mean, for many years, we felt like our genes didn't change over time, and now we know that they do and that they're affected by our environment and a number of other factors. When did the light bulb go off and you said, oh, my gosh, we need to apply this to what we're doing here with this cohort? You know, the first epigenetic finding, started to come out of Michael Meaney's group in Canada with rats rearing their pups and showing epigenetic changes having to do with mothering, having to do with variables that were interesting to clinical psychologists and interesting to the members of APA. That was very exciting. So we already had the DNA. We were early adopters. We were one of the first cohorts worldwide to collect DNA.
领域。我的意思是，多年来，我们觉得我们的基因不会随时间改变，现在我们知道它们会改变，而且它们受到我们的环境和许多其他因素的影响。灯泡什么时候亮起的，你说，哦，天哪，我们需要把这个应用到我们在这里对这个队列所做的事情上？你知道，第一个表观遗传学发现，开始来自加拿大 Michael Meaney 的团队，研究大鼠抚养幼崽，并显示与母性有关的表观遗传变化，与临床心理学家感兴趣的变量有关，也与美国心理学会成员感兴趣的变量有关。这非常令人兴奋。所以我们已经有了 DNA。我们是早期采用者。我们是全球最早收集 DNA 的队列之一，
back when the study members were 26-year-olds, so that was almost 30 years ago now. So we had the DNA already in the lab, and we could then do the assays to look at epigenetic marks on top of the DNA was a natural addition for us. Once it became interesting to psychologists, we went in. How were the biological baselines established? Like, how do you know when biological and chronological systems are in sync?
早在研究成员 26 岁时，所以那已经是近 30 年前了。所以我们已经在实验室里有了 DNA，然后我们可以进行化验来观察 DNA 之上的表观遗传标记，这对我们来说是一个自然的补充。一旦它对心理学家变得有趣，我们就进去了。生物学基线是如何建立的？比如，你们怎么知道生物系统和生理系统何时同步？
Right. Well, we started out when the study members were 26 and we drew these 19 biomarkers. And I should just say there are things like cholesterol, HBA1C, your waist hip ratio, your blood pressure, your dental cavities, lung capacity. Those measures were taken when the study members came in when they were 26 years old. So that was, again, about 25 or 30 years ago. So we had those as their baseline when they were at their peak. of young adult health. And then when they came in, they were 32, we just repeated them. And when they were 38 and when they were 45. So we're able to calculate not only what is normal for a person in the sample, but what is normal for a super healthy young adult. And is that now becoming a standard in this kind of work? Is everybody sharing sort of the same? When you're 40,
对。好吧，我们从研究成员 26 岁时开始，我们提取了这 19 种生物标志物。我应该说，有胆固醇、糖化血红蛋白、腰臀比、血压、牙齿龋洞、肺活量等。这些测量是在研究成员 26 岁时来到诊所时进行的。所以那又是大约 25 或 30 年前了。所以我们把这些作为他们处于年轻成人健康巅峰时的基线。然后当他们 32 岁时，我们只是重复了它们。当他们 38 岁和 45 岁时也是如此。所以我们不仅能够计算出样本中一个人什么是正常的，而且能够计算出超级健康的年轻成人什么是正常的。这现在是否正在成为这类工作的标准？每个人都在分享某种相同的吗？当你 40 岁时，
this is what your biology should look like? You know, no. And the reason why most of the studies that are in this area are people of all multiple ages. So they range in their samples range in age from 18 to 80. And they only have biomarkers at one time point. So what that means is that they're not able to really say, here's our whole population representative sample, what they looked like when they were 26, what they looked like. like in their 30s, what they look like in their 40s, in their 50s. They don't have the data for that. So the Dunedin study is the one that has those data, but it's 1,000 people in New Zealand.
你的生物学应该看起来像这样？你知道，没有。原因在于，该领域的大多数研究都是针对多个年龄段的人。所以他们的样本年龄范围从 18 岁到 80 岁。而且他们只有一个时间点的生物标志物。所以这意味着他们无法真正说，这是我们整个人口代表性样本，他们在 26 岁时看起来是什么样，他们在 30 多岁时看起来是什么样，
So what we're really hoping is that some of the larger American studies will get in the business. Now, the Baltimore Longitudinal Study on Aging is doing it. The Health and Retirement Study that is funded also by the National Institute on Aging is doing it. So, pretty, pretty much. pretty soon we'll have this nutted out for Americans. There's a lot of progress. They've already published some of their findings. It's very exciting. With the Dunedin study, so every year, you bring people in and test them again, is that correct? No, not every year. We bring them in every about five or six years now. We brought them every other year when they were little kids because they were developing so fast. So we saw them at age three and five and seven and nine.
在 40 多岁时，在 50 多岁时。他们没有这些数据。所以达尼丁研究是拥有这些数据的研究，但它只有新西兰的 1000 人。所以我们真正希望的是，一些规模更大的美国研究能加入这个行业。现在，巴尔的摩纵向老龄化研究正在这样做。同样由国家老龄化研究所资助的《健康与退休研究》也在这样做。所以，很快我们就会为美国人弄清楚这一点。进展很大。他们已经发表了一些发现。这非常令人兴奋。关于达尼丁研究，所以你们每年都把人们叫来再次测试，对吗？不，不是每年。我们现在大约每五六年把他们叫来一次。当他们还是小孩子时，我们每隔一年把他们叫来，因为他们发育得太快了。所以我们在 3 岁、5 岁、7 岁和 9 岁时见到了他们，
and so every other year on their odd number birthday. But when they got into adulthood, you know, peer reviewers of our papers always say, you should be bringing these people in every year. And I say, that's great. But I haven't noticed that our funding agencies or the study members are keyed on that idea. So sometimes what would be the perfect methodology for science
所以是在他们奇数生日的那一年。但当他们进入成年期，你知道，我们论文的同行评审员总是说，你应该每年把这些人叫来。我说，那太好了。但我没注意到我们的资助机构或研究成员对这个想法感兴趣。所以有时什么是科学的完美方法，
is not in keeping with the availability of research fundings or with the need for privacy for the participants. So I think we push them about as hard as we can, and we raise money about as fast as we can, but about every five years seems to be what we can manage. Are there new factors you're hoping to be able to look at with this cohort? Yes, you know, when you run a longitudinal study like this, first of all, you have to keep up with what the cohort members tell you
并不符合研究资金的可用性或参与者对隐私的需求。所以我认为我们尽可能地推动他们，我们尽可能快地筹集资金，但大约每五年似乎是我们能做到的。你们是否希望用这个队列观察新的因素？是的，你知道，当你进行这样的纵向研究时，首先，你必须跟上队列成员告诉你的事情，
is the most important thing in their lives. So they're starting to worry about menopause, in retirement now. So we're having to get, you know, learn about that. So we just not, you know, I started out studying juvenile delinquency and drug use and risky sex. And now I'm now I'm having to study menopause, retirement, those kinds of things. And the other thing is that we're trying to make sure that we, in our psychological data and psychological interviews, that we really collect information that is really important for understanding the behavioral and social, aspects of aging. So a lot of what's been done with this cohort seems very biological,
什么是他们生活中最重要的事情。所以他们现在开始担心更年期和退休了。所以我们必须了解这一点。所以我刚开始研究青少年犯罪、吸毒和危险性行为。现在我不得不研究更年期、退休，这类事情。另一件事是，我们正在努力确保，在我们的心理数据和心理访谈中，我们确实收集了对理解衰老的行为和社会方面真正重要的信息。所以这个队列所做的大部分工作看起来非常生物学，
but in fact, that's quite a small part. So for example, we're interviewing extensively this time at age 52 about a construct called apathy. So you may imagine that apathy is interesting because it can be one of the very first signs of movement towards Alzheimer's dementia. When a person long before they show any memory problems, starts just losing enthusiasm for life. They start being a little less social. They start, you know, just being kind of tired and not full of them and vigor as they were before. So when that starts to happen, it's subtle, but you want to get data on it. So we're interviewing the study members about the constructive apathy, and we're interviewing
但事实上，那只是很小的一部分。例如，这次在 52 岁时，我们正在广泛地访谈一个名为“冷漠”的结构。所以你可以想象，冷漠很有趣，因为它可能是迈向阿尔茨海默氏痴呆症的最早迹象之一。当一个人在表现出任何记忆问题很久之前，就开始失去对生活的热情。他们开始变得不那么社交。他们开始，你知道，只是有点累，不像以前那样充满活力。所以当这种情况开始发生时，它是微妙的，但你想获得关于它的数据。所以我们正在访谈研究成员关于冷漠的结构，我们正在访谈
collecting data from their spouses and friends as well. So we have informant reports about that. How do other people see them as less lively than they used to be? Or are they still holding up with their vim and vigor? So your academic background is as a psychologist, but have you had to become a biologist, physiologist? I mean, it seems like you've had to learn a whole lot of other skills in the course of this work. You know, I have, but I also have incredible good collaborators and staff. So they're super patient with me and they bring me along.
也从他们的配偶和朋友那里收集数据。所以我们有关于此的知情人报告。其他人怎么看他们比以前不那么活跃了？还是他们仍然保持着活力？所以你的学术背景是心理学家，但你是否不得不成为生物学家、生理学家？我的意思是，看起来你在工作中不得不学习很多其他技能。你知道，我确实学了，但我也有非常好的合作者和员工。所以他们对我超级有耐心，他们带着我一起进步。
So I would call myself a brain imaging neuroscientist, but Amad Harare is, you know, holding my hand. And he's very kind and patient about explaining everything to me and making sure I fully understand it before we write anything up or publish it. Because we do, you know, when you publish a research paper, you do have to sign something saying that you can explain and defend the findings yourself if you're going to be an author on the paper. So that's really important to me. And I work with my staff and we have bioinformitians. We have wetlam researchers, you know, statisticians on our team who help me. So what are the next big questions you're hoping to answer? Well, we want to know what happens with the pace of aging when we follow it up now at age 52.
所以我称自己为脑成像神经科学家，但 Amad Harare 在牵着我的手。他非常友善和耐心，在我们在写任何东西或发表之前，向我解释一切，并确保我完全理解它。因为我们确实，你知道，当你发表一篇研究论文时，如果你要成为论文的作者，你确实必须签署一份声明，说你可以自己解释和捍卫这些发现。所以这对我很重要。我和我的员工一起工作，我们有生物信息学家。我们团队中有湿实验室研究人员、统计学家，他们帮助我。那么你希望回答的下一个大问题是什么？好吧，我们想知道当我们现在在 52 岁时进行随访时，衰老步伐会发生什么。
According to theory, it should slightly start accelerating. as people age into their 50s and 60s and 70s. So the theory of aging is that it's a little bit like a snowball going downhill. So you age kind of slowly from 20 to 30, start noticing you don't look that great in a bathing suit anymore, but you're still able to do everything. And then 30 to 40 and then 40 to 50 and then it's sort of, you know, can snowball. And if an event happens in your life, like a fall with a broken hip or if your spouse passes away, that can really be the kind of shock to the psychological system that pushes aging, biological aging into a speed-up phase.
根据理论，它应该开始轻微加速。随着人们步入 50 多岁、60 多岁和 70 多岁。所以衰老的理论是，它有点像滚下山的雪球。所以你从 20 岁到 30 岁衰老得有点慢，开始注意到你穿泳衣看起来不再那么好了，但你仍然能做所有事情。然后 30 到 40，然后 40 到 50，然后它有点，你知道，会像滚雪球一样。如果你的生活中发生了什么事，比如摔倒导致髋部骨折，或者如果你的配偶去世了，那真的可能是对心理系统的冲击，将衰老、生物学衰老推向加速阶段。
So that's one of the things that we're hoping to capture. Well, Dr. Moffin, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been really interesting. This is a great work that you're doing. It's a great podcast. It's so fun to be on it. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and
所以这是我们希望捕捉到的事情之一。好吧，Moffitt 博士，我要感谢您今天参加我的节目。这真的很有趣。这是你们正在做的伟大的工作。这是一个很棒的播客。能参加它真是太有趣了。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。如果你喜欢你听到的内容，请订阅并
leave us a review. And for those of you who want to know more about psychology and the work of APA, you can now join us as a supporter. You don't have to be a psychologist. The benefits include a subscription to our award-winning magazine, monitor on psychology, as well as discounts on our books and other publications. So if psychology is your passion, or if you just want to know more about the science, you can become a supporter by visiting at.a. APA.com org slash speaking. That's at.a.apa.org slash speaking. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association.
给我们留下评论。对于那些想更多地了解心理学和美国心理学会工作的人，你现在可以作为支持者加入我们。你不必是心理学家。福利包括订阅我们屡获殊荣的杂志《心理学监测》，以及我们书籍和其他出版物的折扣。所以如果心理学是你的热情所在，或者如果你只是想更多地了解这门科学，你可以通过访问 at.apa.org/speaking 成为支持者。那是 at.apa.org/speaking。如果你有关于未来播客的评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Weinerman 制作。感谢您的收听，代表美国心理学会，
I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是 Kim Mills。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。